time to check back with ted florindo and
those temperatures for the valley now i
understand it's going to get warmer
but you say i shouldn't be putting away
the sweaters just yet right now
yeah not just yet just because it's
january too right because we know the
temperature is going to drop again so
those of you are like hey that is too
soon it's not going to last all week so
that's the good news for you daytime
highs we want to do a comparison
from here to the big d alright and the
reason for that is because we're
actually
warmer milder than dallas 43 degrees
they actually had some snow
in texas yesterday believe it or not
they were all celebrating because
we all know texas it's rare to get
actual snow
in texas the state of texas for sure sky
canyon right now we begin with you
56 degrees along with centennial hills
these are your current temperatures
and like we always say in every newscast
is we'll always switch these up so no
neighborhoods
are left out all right north las vegas
57 degrees aleante 55
whitney ranch green valley 58 55 also
henderson
let's say it's head to mountains edge 56
for you rhodes ranch
included in that spring valley at 56 at
this hour 45 for
boulder city 55 54 degrees in the 40's
also for sandy valley 61 for lockland
at this hour some clouds are sort of
passing through we're seeing those high
thin clouds right now
again these aren't big enough to give us
any type of
shower activity at all not even the
spits of showers
these are just more bark than bite and
they'll be around for this evening may
give us great little sunset
but we have a parade of storms that will
just be impacting the pacific northwest
again after the year one after the other
we just had so much rain lately all
right
we'll get the clouds to rent but not
expecting any rain those clouds will
increase again
overnight and be around also for most of
the day at least the afternoon for
tomorrow there's a look right now at the
future cast
cloudy skies mixed in with some sunshine
tuesday also wednesday
showers stay north though those storms
stay to the north again we've been
seeing that lately
ridges flattened a little bit but we'll
see those storms stay to the north then
we'll see that ridge really start to
shoot way up and give us the milder
temperatures
on wednesday i should say thursday
friday and some of
saturday that ridge goes all the way to
the pacific northwest but by the time we
get to the weekend breezy winds cooler
temperatures come
as that trough digs down deep towards
the east of us so
here's the forecast overnight now 35
degrees
cold and clear we get to the mid 30s
right near freezing
we call that cold because it really is
winds are staying light for the most
part temperatures will be below average
for our
overnight low and the reason for that
also is because we have calm winds
we have the clear skies all that heat
just goes back
into space rather than underneath the
cloud cover 57 degrees for tomorrow
a mix of sun to clouds clouds later on
in the day
neighborhood by neighbor temperatures 54
in summerlin 55 for centennial hills
56 mountains edge 55 for henderson
outside of valley prop at 54 degrees
boulder city you'll be 55
and 65 for laughlin tomorrow afternoon
here's your extended forecast now mild
on thursday remember that record
is 74 degrees we'll come close to record
territory but probably not going to read
it
reach it and that goes for friday and
saturday too and then breezy
by saturday through the weekend as we
see those temperatures right back down
to the
mid 60s again we told you it would be
brief
and there you go christian over to you